[Música]
hola buenas tardes
les voy a pedir que por un momento
imaginen una situación en la que sienten
miedo de salir de casa
en la que de pronto tienen que cambiar
sus hábitos y sus rutinas y que les da
temor encontrarse con otras personas por
ejemplo en el transporte público
imaginan la situación en la que tienes
miedo de morir o que quizás hayas
perdido un ser querido también imagina
una situación en la que todos los días
en las noticias hay historias de dolor y
sufrimiento imagina que la economía está
pasando por una crisis y que hay
negocios que están cerrando
quizá por lo que escuches creas que a lo
que me refiero es a la epidemia por kobe
19 pero no no me refiero a eso quizás lo
pienses porque has experimentado alguna
de estas situaciones pero de lo que
estoy hablando desde la otra epidemia la
epidemia de violencia
[Música]
muchas comunidades en méxico llevan
muchos años viviendo este tipo de
situaciones como las que te describía la
gente tiene miedo de salir de casa tiene
miedo de ser asesinado extorsionado y
secuestrado tiene miedo de que le
desaparezcan a un familiar o le han
desaparecido a un familiar o le han
asesinado a alguien que quiere
también camina hipervigilante en sus
trayectos a su casa o de regreso y tiene
temor de las otras personas tiene temor
incluso de sus vecinos y también tienen
que cambiar sus rutinas todos los días
todos los días también amanecen con
historias llenas de horror y de dolor
si la pandemia la pandemia por kobe 19
lo que nos ha hecho es presentarnos una
situación única en la que por primera
vez personas que no han vivido en un
entorno sumamente violento pueden
comprender y empatizar con aquellas
personas que sí lo han hecho o que sí lo
hemos hecho
la situación ocasionada por que el virus
si esta situación ocasionada por el
virus de covite parece dura y llevas un
año imagínate aquellas comunidades que
llevan más de una década y acapulco lo
sabe bien
se estima que a enero de este año
aproximadamente 150 mil personas han
muerto por el virus de kobe
este mismo número de muertes y de
personas hemos perdido por los últimos
cinco años pero a causa de la violencia
cuál es la diferencia entonces entre
unas muertes y otras porque unas muertes
hacen que se declarara una emergencia
humanitaria y se despliegue toda una
serie de recursos y de esfuerzos y de
cabezas pensando cómo resolver un
problema y para otras no
en mexico los asesinatos las
desapariciones y los feminicidios se
cuentan por miles y si a eso agregamos
la cantidad de escalofriante de
violencia sexual y de violencia familiar
y de violencias contra niñas niños y
adolescentes incluida la explotación
sexual y las redes de trata y
pornografía infantil escuchando esto no
es exagerado decir que en méxico estamos
enfermos de violencia por tanto la
violencia debería atenderse así como un
asunto de salud pública ya en el 2006 la
organización mundial de la salud nos ha
hecho este planteamiento
porque además la violencia es contagiosa
la violencia se transmite de una persona
a otra una persona que experimenta
violencia es muy probable que la
reproduzca y la transmita a otros y la
violencia trae lesiones y muertes además
los expertos nos indican que por cada
víctima de violencia directa hay por lo
menos otras cuatro personas que son
afectadas entre padres hermanos hermanas
familia que se convierten en víctimas
indirectas de la violencia como ya les
había dicho la violencia genera daños
genera daños en personas en familias y
en comunidades en las personas la
violencia es un hecho de sus
desestructurados que genera un trauma
una herida que es una situación
extraordinaria de las que las personas
tienen poca capacidad de recuperarse por
sí mismas y que genera mucha angustia y
mucho miedo
en las personas la violencia genera
daños en su salud física mental y
emocional las víctimas de las violencias
si hablas con ellas te narran cómo son
capaces de conciliar el sueño cómo
sienten un nudo en la garganta y una
opresión en el pecho cómo desarrollan y
cómo desarrollan enfermedades como
diabetes hipertensión les duele el
estómago o la cabeza y muchos otros
padecimientos la madre de una joven
asesinada de nada como si incapaz de
probar bocado y aveces por las mañanas
le cuesta trabajo levantarse y vestirse
y cuidarse y le cuesta trabajo confiar
en sus vecinos y mantener la esperanza
la víctima de un secuestro o
sobreviviente de un secuestro te platica
como es incapaz de salir de su casa por
semanas y le recupera recuperar le
cuesta mucho tiempo recuperar normalidad
o ir a su trabajo o volver a sonreír en
las víctimas y las ccoo en las
comunidades y en las familias también la
violencia tiene efectos devastadores en
una comunidad que sufre de violencia los
lazos se rompe la confianza disminuye y
se que se vive todo el tiempo en un
clima de desolación y de mucha
desesperanza la violencia genera
víctimas y entonces yo pregunto quién
atiende a las víctimas quién las cuida a
quien se encarga de atender ese trauma
por violencia y de reparar esos daños
estamos haciendo lo suficiente por ellas
estamos realmente resolviendo el
problema de la violencia desde mi punto
de vista no y no solamente no lo hemos
resuelto sino que además al combatir la
violencia con más violencia estamos
generando todavía más víctimas y
aumentando la victimización
y todavía peor es que a las víctimas que
ya existen las re victimizamos las
activistas los optimizamos a través de
sistemas corruptos e ineficientes como
los de justicia o mecanismos débiles de
búsqueda o las revisamos nosotros con
narrativas lastimosa hacia demás sin
fundamento de que en algo estaban
metidos y lastimamos un hombre su
dignidad y su memoria mi propuesta es
entonces poner a las víctimas en el
centro me parece que es una ruta que no
ha sido explorada lo suficientemente en
nuestro país porque normalmente lo que
hacemos para atender la violencia en
mexico es poner el foco en el agresor es
decir en quien genera la violencia y no
en quien recibe los daños de esa
violencia por otra parte las víctimas y
los agresores no están tan lejos los
unos de los otros de hecho hay como un
hilo invisible que los une que es la
violencia misma y lo que dicen los
expertos es que el dolor que no se
transforma se transfiere y que detrás de
todo
hay un potencial victimario y que detrae
es un victimario hubo alguna vez una
víctima
entonces el niño que hoy está siendo
golpeado en su casa muy probablemente en
el futuro será un padre golpeador
la mujer a la que hoy le han asesinado
impunemente a su hijo probablemente en
el futuro pague un sicario para que se
haga justicia por su propia mano
es muy probable que un niño que hoy está
siendo explotado sexualmente mañana
recurra a las drogas para buscar paz
pero lastimé su cuerpo hoy que se une a
las filas de la delincuencia y también
es muy probable que una mujer que está
haciendo abusadas sexualmente hoy que no
es atendida en el futuro transfiera esa
violencia de ella misma y se quite la
vida quienes padecen la violencia y no
son acompañados y atendidos tienden a
perpetuar este ciclo de violencia por
eso yo digo que hay que acompañar a las
víctimas para romper este ciclo de
violencia
y bueno como se rompe este ciclo pues
acompañando a las víctimas estando con
ellas haciendo presencia haciéndoles
saber que no están solas y ayudarlas en
su proceso de sanación porque cuando se
acompañan las víctimas en el
restablecimiento de sus derechos y en la
sanación al trauma por violencia se
abren caminos se corta el ciclo de
violencia y se abre caminos hacia la paz
y la reconciliación este acompañamiento
pasa por una serie de momentos y estos
momentos son los siguientes primero lo
que hay que generar es un espacio de
seguridad y de protección para la
víctima después hay que hacer un
ejercicio muy valiente porque hay que
recuperar la memoria y hay que buscar la
verdad y la justicia y también hay que
reparar los daños y además tenemos que
garantizar que no vuelva a suceder y
como se ve esto para la madre del
muchacho desaparecido pues primero
y que ella pueda tener un lugar así más
o menos en el que se sienta segura y
acogida en el que sabe que alguien nos
va a ayudar a buscar a su hijo sin
descanso hasta encontrarlo
para un niño de víctima sexual eso
significa que se generará todo un
mecanismo de protección que los 'cara a
cara' de ese lugar donde está haciendo
victimizado lo pondrá a salvo y pondrá
condiciones para una vida plena la
hermana de un joven asesinado necesita
que se le escuche y que se ponga todo un
acompañamiento sicosocial para sanar el
trauma por violencia pero también se
necesita que se recuerde el nombre de su
hermano y que se limpie su nombre y que
se haga memoria y se honre su vida
la madre de una joven asesinada necesita
verdad necesitas saber qué pasó quién lo
hizo y por qué y también necesita
justicia no necesita rogar por justicia
necesita que se le dé pronta y expedita
para los hijos huérfanos de un hombre
asesinado lo que se necesita es atender
sus necesidades inmediatas necesitamos
hacernos cargo de ellos de su salud de
su educación y de su bienestar porque
porque bueno necesita que se les atienda
porque necesitamos de alguna manera
tratar de reparar el daño que si bien en
algunos casos sabemos que eso es
imposible al menos lo intentaremos
porque hay daños que son irreparables
y para el padre de una joven que
desapareció necesitamos garantizarles
que sus otras hijas están seguras y no
van a desaparecer
necesitamos garantizarle que habernos
identificado cuáles son las fallas en
los sistemas de seguridad que hicieron
que pasara la primera vez y decirle esto
no va a volver a pasar y entonces sólo
entonces cuando las víctimas cuando haya
pasado todo esto y las víctimas decidan
es que podemos empezar a hablar de
perdón de reconciliación y de paz lo que
es evidente para mí es que hoy en méxico
la violencia ha generado una crisis
humanitaria que no se ha atendido por lo
menos no lo suficiente no quiero dejar
de reconocer que hay muchos esfuerzos de
sociedad civil y personas y
organizaciones y defensoras y defensores
instituciones civiles religiosas
académicas e incluso gubernamentales que
se han centrado sus esfuerzos en las
víctimas pero el tamaño del problema es
demasiado grande así que necesitamos
poner en el centro a las víctimas de
hacer mucho más de lo que se hace la
propuesta de centrar el trabajo en la
amistad en las víctimas
además de que es un imperativo ético y
moral es algo que nos conviene a todos
ya todas como sociedad es algo
estratégico pues miren primero que nada
porque nadie ninguno de los que estamos
aquí ni ninguno es inmune a la violencia
todos podemos convertirnos alguna vez en
una víctima de violencia además porque
ellas las víctimas conocen muy bien y
han tenido experiencia en los sistemas
que no funcionan y que es necesario
transformar así que su conocimiento
sobre esas cosas que no funcionan pueden
ser muy útiles para transformar eso que
hay que transformar y finalmente porque
las víctimas se han convertido en las
defensoras de los derechos de todas y de
todos tuyos y los míos dicen los
colectivos de familias de búsqueda de
familias de desaparecidos que hoy por mi
hijo espero que nunca por el tuyo
y si quieres más razones para atender a
las víctimas pues te voy a contar
algunas escucha en los países donde han
sufrido altos índices de violencia o
niveles de violencia muy fuertes pero
que después han atendido a las víctimas
con enfoques integrales y psicosociales
después han visto que hay mucha mayor
participación de las personas en la vida
democrática y en el desarrollo de un
país también hay evidencia que en los
países donde se han generado procesos
con de verdad justicia memoria y
reparación y que han puesto las víctimas
al centro hoy gozan de mejores niveles
de paz de bienestar e incluso mejores
niveles económicos también nos conviene
a poner las víctimas en el centro o es
importante ponerlas en el centro porque
sin ellas no podemos construir la paz
porque en otros países como en sudáfrica
en colombia en perú y en guatemala son
ellas quienes han llevado hasta las
últimas consecuencias toda una serie de
procesos de verdad justicia memoria
reconciliación y paz
si queremos construir la paz en méxico
tenemos que empezar por las víctimas
tenemos que hacerles saber que no están
solas que estamos con ellas y
acompañarlas y voltearla saber tenemos
que hacerles saber que su comunidad y
sus gobiernos las acompañan y las
protegen necesitamos romper los ciclos
de violencia necesitamos sanar las
heridas porque además está comprobado
que aquellas sociedades
en las que están enfermas de violencia o
padecen de mucho trauma por violencia no
se pueden proyectar hacia el futuro
entonces necesitamos romper los ciclos
de violencia para poder dejar atrás esas
más narrativas de miedo y de
desesperanza y poder transitar las
narrativas de esperanza y de futuro
el epicentro del dolor y la tragedia de
la violencia está en las víctimas pero
también la esperanza la esperanza está
en las víctimas y en nosotros si somos
capaces de reflejarnos en ellas y
acompañarlas y cuidarlas y caminar
juntas en este largo proceso de
construir la paz con justicia y dignidad
en méjico
ahora si crees que esto suena una tarea
titánica y que es muy grande y muy
difícil es cierto pero hay niveles de
responsabilidades y es el estado al que
le toca garantizar los derechos y
proteger los derechos de las víctimas
pero a nosotros también podemos hacer
algo por ellas todas y todos y para eso
te voy a contar una historia una
historia que está muy cerca de mi
corazón y que también sucedió aquí en
acapulco en el 2011 un pequeño grupo de
mujeres en las colonias más violentos de
la ciudad acompañadas por dos párrocos
el padre jesús mendoza y el padre
bulmaro hernández se dieron cuenta que
la mejor manera de romper los ciclos de
violencia en sus comunidades
era acompañando las víctimas y entonces
lo que hicieron es con bien poquitos
recursos técnicos y económicos salieron
a buscar a las víctimas y las
acompañaron y las consolaron y las
escucharon y les hicieron saber que no
estaban solas
con el tiempo y la ayuda de
organizaciones locales como la
universidad loyola y de otras nacionales
e internacionales este pequeño proyecto
se convirtió en un modelo de atención en
las víctimas el proyecto de
acompañamiento a víctimas de las
violencias que se llaman pago y se ha
replicado en varios otros lugares del
país y del mundo porque sólo se
transforma actuando a través de este
mismo acompañamiento y este mismo
programa se creó en acapulco el
colectivo familias de acapulco en busca
de sus desaparecidos este colectivo no
solamente busca a sus hijos sino que
ayuda a otras personas a buscar a sus
familias además hace toda una serie de
eventos de prevención en las escuelas y
en las universidades y empuja y exige a
las autoridades en las instituciones
para que se transformen para que tú y yo
no tengamos que pasar por lo que ellas
han pasado es increíble la solidaridad
de estos grupos conformados en su
mayoría por mujeres mujeres y madres que
ya han encontrado a sus hijos
siguen permaneciendo en el colectivo
ayudando a los otros a buscarlos unidas
por lo que ellos llaman nuestro mismo
dolor por el testimonio valiente de
estas mujeres admirables por las
víctimas y sus acompañantes por nur y
tomás jesús don carlos
bulmaro conchita lado de tony amarilla
jose y alguien por emma por gabi por
sergio por jose guadalupe por lucia por
maría y por janet es que te invito a que
pongamos a las víctimas en el centro y
que hagamos de su dolor nuestro dolor y
de su causa nuestra causa muchas gracias
[Música]